Chris what's going on with you and Ralph
I haven't spoken to Ralph in a while are
you guys not talking anymore
yeah we got into a big fight there it
was the dumbest thing we started
fighting over over text about the ending
to the Sopranos
I mean really a stupid thing and then he
snapped and just said you know what you
you don't have the right to comment on
any of this cuz you're just a low-level
writer who writes dick jokes for living
and that's all you'll ever be so you
have a run comment on Sopranos ending
read the text let me see what to caused
all the problems you guys are ridiculous
let me hear this is what I said I'm not
watching a David Lynch movie
give me an ending that was nonsense so
Ralph replied oh yeah that's not what
set me off but it didn't nothing set me
off this was like going on all of us I
admit it
oh yeah you responded you liked the
Joker
Ralph hated the Joker couldn't stand it
oh yeah you like the Joker talk about
desperately trying to be something it
wasn't that's why you'll never write
anything of substance just silly dick
jokes but that's okay stay in your lane
a really nasty person like we were
having a silly argument and you went too
far and I was joking around even when I
say stay and stay in your lane I'm being
stupid like that guy in The Bachelor who
kept saying that that douchebag stay in
your lane they really were really angry
I felt I was attacking your
sensibilities as a tastemaker as a guy
who knows good I hate seeing you two
fight I mean not really but I'm supposed
to say something at some point here's
George wants to talk to Ralph go ahead
George just get it over with and blow
each other you know sounds like it's
going and maybe don't be good friends
it's sexual tension maybe yet maybe
George is right why did you guys try
blowing each other all right Thank You
Ralph
thank you Chris
thank you thank you they fight like an
old married couple
you